oh okay okay okay
i don't know how to start this video oh
my god 64 gigs like get out of here dude
they're both here this is the new
16-inch macbook pro and this is the new
14-inch macbook pro i have been waiting
for a macbook like this pretty much my
entire life maybe on my entire life that
might be exaggerating a little bit maybe
but for like the past couple of years
ever since they removed the sd card slot
the sd card slot is back we have three
thunderbolt 4 ports we have freaking
hdmi ports we even have
mag safe i don't want to talk anymore i
need to open these up because i can't
wait should i open them both at the same
time because i feel like i don't want to
give one more love than the other we're
going to open them both at the same time
okay
i can't pour it up i'll just
space gray 14 inch and we have the
silver 16 inch
oh whoa
it really this is crazy because it
actually i'm oh
it feels like the old school macbooks
it's like the mac is freaking back
the bottom has the macbook like they
have the macbook pro like they had it
engraved oh wow okay so here's the 16
inch oh my god the solder is beautiful
this is it's heavy
i'm so used to that 13 inch wow look i
can't i actually cannot wait to work
the magsafe cable is braided oh shoot
look at that
it's a braided cable i wonder if this
space gray is it darker
no space gray cable same color freaking
bag safe is back full size hdmi a
thunderbolt 4 sd card slot we've got our
other two thunderbolt 4 ports we also
have the 3.5 millimeter headphone jack
and our mag safe hold on a second i got
it i got it i got to do something
oh yeah that is satisfying oh
look at this the brick is
it's not square anymore this is like an
elongated brick check it
check it i also got one of the extension
cables because it's honestly one of the
best purchases that i've ever made
because i
hate plugging this into the wall it
always falls out especially on flights
it just never really stays in so this is
the extension cable so this just plugs
right into the power brick and will give
you a much longer cable this is the 140
watt usbc power adapter that goes to our
16 inch
and 14 inch is still that square size
and this one is a 96 watt charger so you
guys can see the size difference of both
of those it's uh actually it's pretty
significant so with space grey you get
your black stickers let's see if
stickers are white on no actually both
versions give you the black stickers on
that
zapple announced not only one but two
new chips they have the m1 max and the
m1 pro both of those are going to be
incredibly powerful we'll talk a little
bit more about the differences in those
but honestly i just want to open these
up and
that's really what i want to do like
this is giving me such old-school
throwback vibes for some of the old
macbooks
oh look at this oh instant
freaking
i feel like i'm actually going to cry
and i don't want to cry but sometimes i
can't control my emotions and this is
one of those times
look at this i like that they changed
the background for each of the size
variants so on the 14 inch
they've got like this little red
background and on the 16 they have the
blue now i'm like debating
did i make the right choice on the size
of the laptop that i got because for the
past year i've been using the 13 inch
macbook and i got very used to that
smaller screen size so
i ordered the completely specked out
macbook pro 16 inch but this 14
is a very
nice size and traveling
with the 13 inch was so great because it
was so much smaller
but look at this
this is this is thick this is beefy
editing on this is gonna be a freaking
dream the keyboard is all new it also
looks so strange without the touch bar
it's like it's naked here it's like
where did your
where'd your clothes go it's really
fresh super clean so this is the base
model 14 inch macbook pro this has the 8
core m1 pro chip it has 16 gigs of ram
and 512 gigs of storage and this is
gonna run you about two thousand dollars
that is the entry level and this is
still going to be so incredibly powerful
if you're looking to save some money but
still want to get one of these updated
machines this could be the way to go i
have been editing some incredibly
processor intensive things over the past
year on that 13-inch m1 macbook i have
pushed that thing to its absolute limits
so the fact that
this is an upgrade from that i think a
lot of people are going to be incredibly
surprised with this base model but then
on the other hand for over here we've
got the 16 inch the apple m1 max chip
with 64 gigs of ram this has four
terabytes of storage and this is the 10
core model so there are various
configurations that you guys can choose
look how big these speakers are holy
moly let's check out these ports so over
here we have our magsafe we've got our
two thunderbolt
4 ports we've got our headphone jack
and we have our full size hdmi out which
is so impressive another thunderbolt 4
and our sd card slot
you can see the hinge also looks very
different than the previous version and
this bottom like i love
that macbook pro font like that looks
great i'm actually kind of digging the
silver i had been going all space gray
over the past couple of years but the
silver really is kind of that throwback
because this is what the original
macbooks look like i like the rounded
edges
there are gonna be a lot of very happy
apple people
when these start shipping
[Music]
[Applause]
i have been playing with the new
macbooks all weekend and i'm so excited
you guys may have remembered nathan
you've been having videos before you
used to shoot a ton of stuff together
yeah yeah so i hit you up and i go yo i
got i know you've got some crispy ak
footage i do
there it is brought it with me so i'm so
excited because i obviously edit a ton
in final cut but you've been editing
recently in resolve yeah i switched to
resolve like around version 15. so what
do you mostly shoot you know i've been
doing a lot of different things some
corporate videos some big commercials
some music videos and then like some fun
small scripted projects nathan shoots
tons of crazy high quality stuff so i
was like i know you've got some footage
can you bring some over and can you do a
little workflow test to see how this new
m1 macbook stands in comparison to like
what you've been using and i've been on
a 2018 uh fully loaded macbook pro since
2018. i'm going from intel to just the
first interaction with an apple chip
well let's interact
[Music]
dude this is it
so this is the 16 inch this has the m1
max and i also have the 14 inch here and
honestly
the craziest thing about this is the
fact that we can get all of the same
specs in the 14 inch put 64 gigs of
rounds in the 14. and an 8 terabyte
solid state drive i edited this entire
youtube video all of this in bed with a
blanket i heard oh that's not a single
fan
barely got more so this is 422 10 bit so
you've been shooting a ton of ak footage
recently i've been shooting a ton of ak
footage on the canon there's a crumb on
here that's uh from a muffin i had
earlier we don't have to look at that
okay i'm going to open up this ak
library pop in some of your footage and
final cuts and i did have to install a
canon plug-in because you shot this on
the r5
canon r5 this is not the raw light this
is the full-blown raw i am really
excited to see what this computer can do
with this footage because this footage
is a beast i cannot work with this
footage in its native state right out of
the camera ak raw here we go this looks
good this looks amazing i want to see
what you did so how did you click
where's the optimize button so it's over
here so if you go into view so you can
do better performance theoretically you
can just start cutting right out of the
camera and should we do a little color
like we want to add some so if this was
mine i'd be like let's up this
saturation all the way
do it
there's a lot in there let's
do it this is so fun having like the
second display but the crazy thing about
this is like i can do all of this on
this the resolution on here is nuts no
look at that how's that look for you i
think that looks great should we send it
off to the client
how about this nice little tint
i mean these are adding these onto this
ak footage like real time and it's still
playing i'm still playing back what if
we add let's just get a little crazy and
add
there's this is still cruising still
cruising this isn't even like progress
this is still the raw one two three four
five
stacking this is wild so i want to see
like kind of what you would be doing in
resolve i again have not really used
resolve very much
my heart just stopped we i think we
might have a defibrillator just in case
uh
this isn't the same is this not
something that happens we're playing
back 8k raw
over 8 we're 81.92 by 4320 at 24 frames
we don't have optimization turned on we
don't have proxies rendered the hard
thing is like we're showing you this and
it's running so seamless that having any
type of comparison like you don't
understand like this is things that you
could not do before could not do can i
just apologize why everyone's gonna
comment that i wrote justin's stuff when
we started this project okay i'm so
embarrassed i haven't remedied the
situation it's now justine's stuff and
we've also got the studio version now of
resolve we've got your key in and now
what what are you gonna show us okay
we're gonna look at noise reduction the
footage doesn't need it but noise
reduction is one of those things where
if you have the coolest computer in the
world and you add a full-blown layer of
davinci resolve temporal noise reduction
it's going to slow it down temporal
noise reduction keying off of every five
frames motion estimation type better
well yeah you gotta you gotta if this
plays are you gonna freak out i don't
know what i'm gonna do well you're
obviously gonna go bye i won't even hear
you hit the space bar
[Music]
okay
he's gone he's gone he nathan has left
us
he's gone to the apple store do you want
to cry should i get you a tissue are you
gonna be okay i'm not sure help me open
up another line of credits
this is really amazing i mean the fact
that this is really going to be game
changing i feel like for so many people
especially if you're just on sets and
you want to just
put in this ak footage right there i
mean for you you're out in the field too
in a battery life the battery life on
the m1 was so absolutely impressive on
the 13 inch and this one has been
significantly improved this is the
baseline 14 inch you can also do two pro
display xcrs but on the 16 inch you can
do three pro display xdrs plus
an output of a 4k tv so just in case you
needed a little bit extra so this is the
same ak footage that we're working with
on the 16 inch completely specked out
this is the baseline 14 inch on the m1
pro chip of the new computers the new
laptops this is the cheapest i can get
yes let's see what we can do all right
we're gonna just
drop that in oh come on oh it's playing
how is it doing this
oh my goodness i quit
well no don't quit i buy just you bye
but like how much time you're gonna be
saving like honestly i think that's the
thing that a lot of people who aren't
doing the type of high-end work that you
know a lot of people in production are
doing or even like me and tyler are
doing on youtube like this is going to
save us
days days of time waiting for things to
render waiting for things to export it's
actually incredibly impressive let's
just live out on a filter yeah
oh okay it's fine yeah that's great it
looks nice here let's just add on
another one okay cool
this is the not the extreme chip this is
the m1 pro the pro chip with only 16
gigabytes of ram 512 gigs of solid-state
drives the smallest is the smallest the
smallest the cheapest the cheapest the
cheapest and you see what we're doing
and it's still able to do this and it's
hand it's pushing it out to this big
screen over here this is nutty now let's
flip it completely oh my god look at
this this is a book
the fan is finally turning on
finally
it took how many layers we have to count
how many layers did you have 11 12 13 14
15 effects
before the fan even turned on like my
old 16 inch macbook like if you even
just turn it on
it's it's like okay ten times ten times
louder than this
okay resolve
oh i and i had resolve open that whole
time what
it was open while we were doing this
itunes you have music open
oh i didn't even notice notes oh geez
okay so we correction while we were
doing that how many tabs in safari oh a
couple multiple safari
yeah we had resolve open while we were
doing that test can you believe that
oops resolves open
show me what you got well uh yeah i mean
i feel like we know we're gonna get this
is gonna be
amazing and aka footage in a 1080
timeline and here comes some temporal
noise reduction and we're going to max
it out
here comes the boy okay here we go so it
did 18 frames i believe last time 1890
frames it's still playing though
do you what does it do for you on
youtube first of all i can't even play
the dot crm file so that plays in
real-time then we add noise reduction
it's but it's still playing it's like
yeah that's still doable yeah and still
yeah
i hear the fan a little bit
do you i think that might
i think that's the light over there that
i don't think that's the fan okay but if
you don't know if you hear it like what
the that's fair i swear i think it's
that light
the real contrasty
saturation already i mean like that's
where we started yeah that's a big
difference
and then
we haven't added any saturation no i'd
probably make it like a little warmer
maybe just because i feel like there's a
lot of like i'd like some some warmth in
those rocks oh this is so fun telling
somebody else what to do yeah little
masking mask and then it's an unusual
shape so we'll draw it there we go so
that's a little
crazy no that's great i like it wow okay
that's crazy now it's like lava rocks
let's see how fast it'll track okay so
we'll go here oh so you do have tracking
tracker nice boom it just automatically
analyzed all of these motion tracking
points and then i'm going to play
backwards and it's going to track
reverse it looks a little weird once it
gets covered with i don't think so i
don't think so because it looks like
there's something underneath yeah
because there is something underneath it
um just as a reminder the lowest end
yeah we're doing all of this new macbook
i can just sit here and play all day
long me too but unfortunately we have to
go edit this video and post it tomorrow
so well then boy wow i think i'm gonna
go get one yeah you should you really
should you should you should you should
okay nathan how are you feeling after
our edit session my mind is blown most
blown with the 14 inch mat i was
surprised too because i hadn't done any
extensive testing because i edited my
entire sewing project on the 16 inch
right and was so blown away by that i'm
even more impressed by the baseline
14 inch and it's like we're doing
high-end processor intensive things so
just everyday tasks for people doing
simple photo editing email everything
loads so fast and snappy i
okay so i'm sure you've probably done
this but i've accidentally selected all
and then opened up a bunch of images and
photoshop yes by accident so i opened up
a like probably like 45 it was a
ridiculous amount of 4k clips by
accident that's when you just command
quit the whole you shut down the whole
computer
by the time it would have taken me to
force quit the entire finder they were
already open and playing and i was like
what this is on the new one yes
it was like so mind-blowing so it's like
simple things like that that i think
people aren't realizing is gonna impact
them on just sort of like a like a
baseline level like you can load things
so quick we're gonna be super spoiled
yeah i mean i was super spoiled when i
got the mac pro and now i'm like okay
this macbook is actually going to be
replacing an entire computer which
is that is so crazy do you hear what
you're saying yeah i mean the mac pro
that i have now is a completely specked
out model i don't even know what the
price of it is in total and it's it's
it's tens of thousands of dollars by the
time we have the the monitors the
updated ram the afterburner everything
completely specked out and now to go to
this
a six thousand dollar macbook why would
they or even a two thousand dollar
macbook to completely replace it it's
like they out invented themselves it's
really impressive and i know that i'm
the kind of person that like i need to
be more present i need to live in the
now but when that 13-inch macbook came
out i knew that whatever was coming out
next was going to be ridiculous and this
is still setting up because we don't
even have a an imac pro yet we're going
to definitely see another mac pro
the new chip yes so just think about
where we are now and like what the
future is going to hold i'm going to
live in the now i'm going to enjoy my
16-inch macbook pro this is amazing or
maybe i'm going to actually switch to
the inch i'm not sure which one i really
even want now the 14 inch makes sense
for you and how you travel i like the 16
inch for the real estate just showing
client because a lot of times you're
editing you're right there front center
i'm doing something for a client they're
over my shoulder and those two inches of
real estate that helps it makes actually
a really big difference i mean i really
enjoyed telling you to make those rocks
a different color like this is really
cool telling somebody else what to do
wow why don't we do that more often i
don't know we can we should yeah i think
we should do that usually there's not
enough time like i have to you know stay
up all night and edit and i can't make
somebody else do that so it's like just
you you're just gonna suffer so that's
what we do oh my goodness well nathan
thank you so much for joining me thank
you so much glad that you really got to
experience this because i really wanted
to have somebody else's perspective to
make sure that like i wasn't just super
impressed and being a fan girl right
that this was justified yeah no like
legitimate this will save me
days and it's just like you think about
how time i mean time is money and it's
sad but the ability to shoot 8k raw and
finish it with the client the same day
that i shot it not have to render
proxies like that's going to change my
whole workflow that's going to pay for
this macbook for you okay i'll go buy it
right
sold
well nathan thank you so much i'll put
all of his links in the description
where you can go check out some of his
work super talented so awesome thank you
so much for joining me i look forward to
seeing your review of the macbook after
you go shopping today after you leave
here no pressure nathan we'll see you
guys later again if you haven't already
please subscribe make sure you hit the
bell and leave us some comments below
about i don't even know like are you
impressed because i'm impressed nathan's
impressed i'm so impressed can't wait to
see what everyone does with this thing
it's going to be amazing i'll see you
guys later bye
you